Hi, this is Steve Zahn, and I just went through an intense tech setup with my mic and my computer, and I'm ready to go. I'm just waiting here. I'm waiting patiently to be on Smartless. Welcome to Smartless. All right, surprise guests. Give us a clap if you're still with us, please. We are rolling. Oh, wow, that's intense.
嗨，我是史蒂夫·赞恩，我刚刚经历了麦克风和电脑的疯狂技术调试，现在我准备好了。我就在这里等着。我正耐心地等着上《Smartless》。欢迎来到《Smartless》。好的，神秘嘉宾。如果你还在听，请给我们鼓个掌，谢谢。我们开始了。哦，哇，太激烈了。
That's a dude. we're going to go tarps off today guys I almost sent you an article last night so we talked about tarps off it wasn't even a Canadian article I never heard that before is that an old saying yeah it is I never heard that Canadian old
那是个人。今天我们要脱掉上衣了，伙计们。昨晚我差点给你们发了一篇文章，所以我们聊到了“脱掉上衣”，甚至都不是加拿大的文章。我以前从来没听过，那是句老话吗？是的，是的。我从没听过那是什么加拿大老话。
You know when I was in junior high school they would do shirts Oh hang on let me settle in They would do shirts and skins You know like And I was so like I would always be afraid to be skins because I wasn't happy with my body.
你知道的，当我读初中的时候，他们会玩“光膀子”游戏。哦，等等，让我调整一下。他们会玩“有衫”对“光膀子”。你知道的，就像……我总是很害怕当“光膀子”的那一方，因为我对自己的身材不满意。
Same. By the way, it's traumatic for children to be like, hey, take your shirts off, dudes, against the guys who get to keep them on. It's like, why is that a thing? Yeah, I wonder if you can still do that. Is it politically not okay to say, you take your shirt off, you keep yours on?
我也是。顺便说一句，让孩子们经历这种事太受心理创伤了，比如：“嘿，脱掉你们的上衣，小伙子们，跟那些不用脱的人对抗。”这就像，为什么会有这种事？是的，我在想你现在还能这么做吗。说“你把衬衫脱了，你留着”在政治上还行得通吗？
And the same, right, and the same was showers after. Like, I remember being 12 years old, guys hit the showers. I'm like, I don't want to be naked in front of my... Were you always on the shower team? Guys, can I be talking about, Team Captain showers? What sport are you doing this semester?
还有同样地，对吧，还有后来的淋浴。就像，我记得我12岁的时候，大家去冲澡。我就想，我才不要在我的……面前赤身裸体呢。你一直是淋浴组的吗？伙计们，我能谈谈吗？队长淋浴？这学期你参加什么运动？
I'm taking showering. I'm quarterback of the shower team. You know, though? Isn't that so traumatic? Yeah, I went to all boys boarding school, dude. I had to shower every day. I mean, what is the thinking behind that? That, like, oh, they'll be fine.
我选修了淋浴课。我是淋浴队的四分卫。不过你知道吗？难道这不让人觉得很有创伤吗？对，我上的是全男校寄宿学校，老兄。我每天都得洗澡。我的意思是，这背后的想法是什么？就是那种，“哦，他们会没事的。”
They'll work it out. They're just boys. And I'm like, no, we're all sensitive. Anyway, moving on. Huh. Huh. Well, just drop us off right there, Sean. Thanks.
“他们会搞定的。他们只是男孩子。”而我想说的是：不，我们都很敏感。总之，言归正传。哈。哈。好吧，就把我们扔在这儿吧，肖恩。谢谢。
I guess we'll find our way home from here. No, you know what I mean? It was just awful. It was awful. I was in camp. I remember I had to take music camp. Oh, he's got more. Shot.
我想我们得自己找路回家了。不，你知道我的意思吗？这太糟糕了。太糟糕了。我在夏令营里。我记得我不得不参加音乐夏令营。哦，他还有更多故事。说吧。
Go ahead. Off the top of my head with Sean Hayes. Yeah. Camp stories. I had to take a shower and it was really cold. But did I hear to tell the story? Oh, that explains it. There's a super long line.
说吧。肖恩·海斯专栏。是的。夏令营的故事。我得洗个澡，水真的很冷。但我是来听故事的吗？哦，这就解释得通了。队伍排得超级长。
And there was a line of like 100 guys in line to take one shower at a time. And by the time I got there, the water was so cold. I was, it was freezing. And I, you know, you'd lose your breath when the water's not, like, you can't get your breath. And I was like, and everybody was staring at me, taking a shower.
有一百来个人排队等着用同一个淋浴间，一次只能进一个。等轮到我的时候，水已经冷透了。我整个人都在结冰。而且你知道的，水不够热时你会喘不过气来，就是那种喘不上气的感觉。我就想，而且每个人都在盯着我洗澡。
I don't know, it's just so awkward. Did your folks get a deal on the camp? This is 100 people for the one shower with the no hot water? Yeah, right. The music camp was awkward. Wait a second, that's it? Yeah, I mean, it's just... Full story.
我不知道，这实在太尴尬了。你爸妈是不是在夏令营上捡到便宜了？一百个人共用一个没有热水的淋浴间？是的，没错。那个音乐夏令营真尴尬。等等，这就没了？对，我的意思是，就这样……完整的故事。
Just the same as always. Well, I think we can start rolling now. Sean, you've got a GEPD hat on that is some sort of a police department that is... Glen Ellen. Glenn Ellen. Glenn Allen. Glenn Aaron. Glenn Aaron.
跟平时一样。好吧，我想我们现在可以开始录了。肖恩，你戴着一顶GEPD的帽子，那是某种警局的……格伦埃尔恩。格伦埃尔恩。格伦艾伦。格伦埃伦。
That's in the Chicago suburbs. That is in... I'm just looking in the chat there. I don't know if you guys want to click on that. Oh, yeah. The chat, there's Jason with the Chicago. Let me see. Towling off in the Mediterranean.
那是芝加哥的郊区。那是……我正在看聊天室。我不知道你们想不想点进去。哦，是的。聊天室里，杰森也来自芝加哥。让我看看。在地中海擦干身子。
Hey, man, you know. Keep it relatable. That's something you can Google if anybody wants to Google. You do look good though, J.B. Yeah, you look really good. No, not really. That's a dad bod right there. That's a dad bod who's been working out.
嘿，老兄，你知道的。保持接地气。如果你想谷歌一下，这是你可以谷歌的东西。不过你看起来确实不错，J.B.。对，你看起来真的很好。不，其实没有。那就是标准的“老爸身材”。那是经常锻炼的老爸身材。
Oh, that is... So that's my shower shot, right? I know. See? It's embarrassing. You're never nude, right? God, remember that show. Yeah. By the way, I got a bunch of...
哦，那是……所以那是我的淋浴照，对吧？我知道。看？这太尴尬了。你从来不裸体，对吧？天哪，还记得那个节目吗。对。顺便说一句，我有一堆……
I think it's, I want to give out the correct website, but I'm going to guess at Davidcross.com. But I went on David's website for his, you know, stand-up site, where he's got a lot of his performances on there, which is awesome. And I bought myself a bunch of swag. I've got David Cross T-shirts. That's cool. No one's great.
我想，我想给出正确的网址，但我盲猜一个 Davidcross.com。但我上了大卫的网站，就是他的那个单口喜剧网站，上面有很多他的表演，太棒了。我给自己买了一堆周边。我买了大卫·克罗斯的T恤。太酷了。没有一个不棒的。
And they threw in a beer cozy. I said to picture to David, once it arrived at the house, I said, hey man, I just wanted you to know, I'm a fan, and I've been buying stuff. I don't know what site I was on, but it was some sort of a link or somehow I got to his website,
他们还送了一个啤酒保温套。等它寄到家里后，我给大卫拍了张照片，我说：“嘿，老兄，我只是想让你知道，我是你的粉丝，我一直在买你的东西。我不知道我上的是哪个网站，但通过某种链接或者不知怎么的我就进了他的网站，”
and I was like, oh, look at all of this stuff. He's got merch, you guys. That's great. So, I don't know, if you like David Cross, like I do, go get yourself a T-shirt with his beautiful face on. We love ourselves from David Cross. Yeah, yeah, he should come back on the show. He should.
然后我就想：“哦，快看这些东西。伙计们，他有周边。”太棒了印着他那张帅脸的T恤。我们都爱大卫·克罗斯。对，对，他应该再来上节目。他应该来的。
We're doing repeats now, aren't we? We're going to do repeats. Well, this one's not. No, this is a fresh new meat. This is fresh new meat. And this is... With heavy hands. Yeah, a loud clap.
我们现在在播重播节目了，对吧？我们要播重播了。好吧，这一期可不是。不，这是新鲜出炉的新鲜货。这是新鲜货。而且这个……带着沉甸甸的掌声。
Yeah. This guy knows how to clap. Sure, he does. And he probably learned it from all the audiences clapping for him. He's a musician? He's not a musician. He's a performer.
是的。这家伙懂得怎么鼓掌。他当然懂。他大概是从所有为他鼓掌的观众那里学来的。他是音乐家吗？他不是音乐家。他是表演者。
A magician, maybe. He's an... His acting is sometimes magic. You know how good magicians are a podcast. We learned that lesson. Look at this. They're an easy booking. Watch that.
魔术师，也许吧。他是一个……他的演技有时就像变魔术。你知道优秀的魔术师怎么做播客吗？我们吸取了那个教训。看看这个。他们很好约。看着吧。
I would describe some of his performances as magic. He grew up in Minnesota. There was a time where he thought about joining the Marines before he started pursuing acting. And then we got to see him in so many amazing shows, movies and stuff over the years. Way back when, all the way to today, movies like Reality Bites,
我会把他的某些表演形容为魔术。他在明尼苏达州长大。在他开始追求演艺事业之前，曾有一段时间他考虑过加入海军陆战队。然后这些年来，我们在那么多精彩的电视剧、电影和其他作品中看到了他。从很久以前一直到今天，像《现实的创痛》这样的电影，
which he was so good. And he does the thing where he goes through independent film and big studio films. And then he does like Crimson Tide with Tony Scott. And then he was in that thing you do, which has become like a cult hit. And then he did Happy Texas, which he was amazing in. I remember him in Suburbia. You guys, it's Steve Zon. How about it?
他在里面演得太棒了。而且他游刃有余地穿梭于独立电影和大制片厂电影之间。然后他演了托尼·斯科特的《赤色风暴》。然后他演了那部后来成为邪典经典的《挡不住的奇迹》。然后他演了《幸福德州》，他在里面的表演简直绝了。我还记得他在《郊区天国》里的表现。伙计们，他就是史蒂夫·赞恩！大家欢迎！
Oh, Steve Zon. I love Steve Zon. I know me some Steve Zon. Sam Rockwell was showing me some pictures of Steve Zon the other day. And I just lit up like a tree. I didn't even get a chance to mention his movie She Dances, which is available now, which I wanted to get into. Steve will ask you about that. But welcome to Smartless Man, huge fan.
哦，史蒂夫·赞恩！我爱死史蒂夫·赞恩了。我对史蒂夫·赞恩略知一二。萨姆·罗克韦尔前几天还给我看了一些史蒂夫·赞恩的照片。我当时就像一棵树一样瞬间点亮了。我甚至还没来得及提他的电影《她跳舞》，这部电影现在已经上映了，我本来想聊聊这个。史蒂夫，等下我们会问你关于这部电影的事。不过欢迎来到《Smartless》，老兄，我是你的超级粉丝。
Thank you. I'm so stoked to be on this show. This is a guest. Yeah, this is a guy. I'm a big fan of your, Steve. Big fan. I'm a fan of all you guys. And I got to say, like, how is it that in 30 years I have not been in the same room with any of you?
谢谢。能上这个节目我太兴奋了。这可是一位重磅嘉宾。是的，这家伙厉害。我是你的超级粉丝，史蒂夫。超级粉丝。我是你们所有人的粉丝。我得说，怎么会这样呢：30年来我竟然从未和你们任何一个人在同一个房间待过？
I know. Where are you living? Where do you and your macaroni art live? That's the name of his production. Macaroni art. Yeah, you got a piece of Macaroni art. Is the name of his production company, right? Is that true?
我知道。你住在哪里？你和你的通心粉艺术住在哪里？那是他的制作公司的名字。通心粉艺术。是的，你有一件通心粉艺术品。那是他的制作公司的名字，对吧？是这样吗？
That's it. That's crazy. So, listener, you should know there's a painting behind him with an elbow macaroni upside down in the shape of a U, just over his left shoulder. That's it. It's a brick wall, Steve, and some art that is macaroni. That's the name of his company. And the brick wall is in midway content.
就是这样。太疯狂了。所以，听众朋友们，你们应该知道，他身后挂着一幅画，上面有一个倒过来的字母U形状的弯管通心粉，就在他左肩膀上方。就是这样。那是一堵砖墙，史蒂夫，还有一些用通心粉做的艺术品。那是他公司的名字。而那堵砖墙就在中部地区。
Kentucky. Wow. Well, that's why we haven't seen you for 30 years. Yeah. Well, I've, you know, I've, you know, I've, you know, I've always, I've always kind of lived outside, outside the world. Yeah. I like that. But thank God you're still finding your way to our, to our movie screens and TV screens. Yeah. Did you ever live in Los Angeles, Steve? No, because, you know, back in the day when you actually worked in Los Angeles, I would just, I would rent a place for a long time, and it was great. Oakwoods. Yeah, I've stayed at the Oakwoods and Marina del Rey when I did that thing you do. Uh-huh. But so I was like, well, if I can run a house for an extended period of time and live in a different neighborhood all the time, why'd buy?
肯塔基州。哇。好吧，难怪我们30年没见过你。对。好吧，我，你知道的，我，你知道的，我，你知道的，我总是，我总是有点生活在外面，生活在世界之外。是的。我喜欢这样。但感谢上帝，你还是找到了通往我们的电影屏幕和电视屏幕的路。是的。史蒂夫，你曾经在洛杉矶住过吗？没有，因为你知道的，当年你在洛杉矶真正工作的时候，我只会租一个地方住很久，那感觉真好。橡树林公寓。是的，我拍《挡不住的奇迹》时就住在玛丽娜德尔雷的橡树林公寓。嗯哼。但当时我就想，如果我能长期租一栋房子，每次都住在不同的街区，我为什么要买房呢？
Right. But I was New York. I was New York. You were. Okay. Yeah. And then I met my wife a long time ago, 1990. And we met doing national tour, Bye Bye Birdie.
对的。但我属于纽约。我属于纽约。你确实是。好的。是的。然后很久以前我遇到了我妻子，1990年。我们是在做全国巡演《再见小鸟》时认识的。
Oh, wow. I'm in. With Tom, cool, Chuck. With Tommy Tune and Ann Rankin. Now you really take it easy, Sean. It was crazy. Fuck. Which part were you? I was Hugo.
哦，哇。我懂。跟汤姆，酷，查克。跟汤米·图恩和安·兰金。现在你可真轻松啊，肖恩。太疯狂了。操。你演的是哪个角色？我是雨果。
Of course you're Hugo. It was 13 months on the road. Anyway, we got back and then we had, you know, we had tour money. We thought we were rich. And so we bought a little cabin in Pennsylvania. And then we didn't work. So we had to give up the apartment and then live in this cabin. And then we commuted.
你当然是雨果。在路上待了13个月。总之，我们回去了，然后我们有了，你知道的，我们有了巡演赚的钱。我们觉得自己很有钱。所以我们在宾夕法尼亚州买了一个小木屋。然后我们没工作了。所以我们不得不放弃公寓，搬进这个小木屋里住。然后我们开始通勤。
to New York. So really early on... You got used to not being in the city. Yeah, exactly. So... Well, now, and you're not the kind of fellow that needs to go in there and take a bunch of meetings.
去纽约。所以很早就……你习惯了不在城市里生活。是的，正好。所以……好吧，现在，你也不是那种需要进城去开一堆会的人。
People know what's going on with Steve's on. They know what they know. It's like you make a call. You see if he's available. It's a lot of get-me-steves-on. Any chance Steve's on is available? I don't care where we've got to fly him in from. Yeah.
大家都很清楚史蒂夫·赞恩的现状。他们心里都有数。这就像你打个电话。看他有没有空。有很多“把史蒂夫·赞恩给我找来”的情况。史蒂夫·赞恩有哪怕一点可能抽出空来吗？我不管我们得从哪把他用飞机接过来。是的。
We just need him. Yeah. No. You know. Yeah. You're like a special firefighter. I will... I will say, Steve, I remember hearing that you are like a special fireman.
我们就是需要他。是的。不。你知道的。是的。你就像个特种消防员。我必须……我必须说，史蒂夫，我记得听说你就像个特种消防员。
Let's get him in here and put it out. He's a problem solve. You solve problems for people. I'm a solving problem. No, but I remember hearing that you lived in like Pennsylvania or something. And I way back when, because I was always such a fan. I was always like, that's so fucking cool that he doesn't even live in the city. Yeah, we don't have.
把他弄来把火扑灭。他是个解决问题的人。你为人们解决问题。我是个问题解决者。不，不过我记得听说你住在宾夕法尼亚州还是什么地方。很久以前，因为我一直是你的超级粉丝。我总是觉得：他甚至都不住在城里，这特么太酷了。是的，我们没有。
The three of us don't have the balls to live outside the city. I certainly, I'm too afraid to miss the meeting. I know. You know? Oh, you guys are on New York. right? No, just soft L.A.
我们三个可没有胆子住在城外。我当然，我太害怕错过会议了。我知道。你知道吗？哦，你们都在纽约，对吧？不，只有软弱的洛杉矶。
You're an L. I'm both. I live in New York for you. Sean, he's got both too. These guys are doing real well, Steve. Yeah. No, but I was a New York guy back in the 90, you know, for 20 years.
你是个洛杉矶人。我两个地方都有。我在纽约为你生活。肖恩，他两个地方也都有。这些家伙现在混得很好，史蒂夫。是的。不，不过我在90年代是个地道的纽约人，你知道的，待了20年。
Man, just what you thought you were doing good. Yeah. You know what, Steve, it's true when Jason just said, wherever he is will make it work. You pop up and like, when you popped up in the White Lotus, I was like, oh my God, you're brilliant in that.
老兄，就在你觉得自己混得不错的时候。是的。你知道吗，史蒂夫，刚才杰森说得没错，无论你在哪，我们都会让它成行。你总是突然出现，就像你在《白莲花度假村》里突然出现时，我就想：哦，天哪，你在里面太绝了。
And then I watched Silo, and I was like, is that Steve Zon? Is that Steve Zon behind the door? And that was amazing. Thanks. You pop up in the most unique places. How do you, do they come to you? Is it something you seek out?
然后我看了《末日地堡》，我就想：那是史蒂夫·赞恩吗？门后面那是史蒂夫·赞恩吗？那太精彩了。谢谢。你总是出现在最独特的那些地方。你是怎么做到的？是他们来找你的吗？这是你主动寻找的吗？
You're like, I love that show because it seems like you're on all the good ones. Well, no, Silo, they approached me. Rebecca did. She actually, Rebecca saw a short that we did, that macaroni art did. We did a series of shorts called Uncandid Portrait. And I played this, like, I played this fictional artist, this photographer. that's famous from taking photographs of fireworks. And it was just short, and she saw it.
你就像是“我爱死那个节目了”，因为你好像演的全都是好剧。噢，不，《末日地堡》是他们来找我的。丽贝卡找的我。事实上，丽贝卡看过我们做的一个短片，就是“通心粉艺术”制作的短片。我们做了一系列名为《坦诚肖像》的短片。我演了一个，我演了一个虚构的艺术家，一个因拍摄烟花而闻名的摄影师。那只是个短片，她看了。
She was like, oh, my God, he'd be perfect for this part. Yeah, for my sister, for my sister who doesn't watch, it's Rebecca Ferguson, brilliant actress. Yes, she's amazing. And really cool. Anyway, but White Lotus, that was one of the last times I went on tape. Yeah, wow. Audition.
她就觉得：哦，天哪，他太适合这个角色了。是的，为了我那个不怎么看剧的妹妹，那是丽贝卡·弗格森，才华横溢的女演员。是的，她太棒了。而且真的很酷。不管怎样，但《白莲花》，那是我最后几次录制试镜带的时候之一。是的，哇。试镜。
And now what about that process? Do you prefer it to self-tapping as opposed to going into a room? I don't do it that much. I mean, usually I get an offer, but it's like... But it's nicer, right? Because you don't have to send it in until you're happy with it. Exactly. I was always afraid I was going to shit my pants in the room, you know?
现在对于那个流程你有什么看法？相比于去现场试镜，你更喜欢自己录试镜带吗？我其实不经常做这个。我的意思是，通常我直接就能拿到邀约，不过……但这样更好，对吧？因为在你自己满意之前，你都不用把它交上去。完全正确。我以前总是很害怕在试镜房间里拉裤子，你知道的。
Yeah. Right. Well, that's because you're in all those diuretics, too. Yeah. It's just trying to drop water weight. It's constantly. It just runs havoc with the valve. But you know what?
对。没错。好吧，那是因为你吃了一堆利尿剂。对。就是试图减掉水分体重。没完没了的。这完全把阀门搞乱了。但你知道吗？
And also it's like whenever I remember reading, you know, being in New York and going in an auditioning at like three of us and there was like 70 guys there. Three of us. You know, remember that? And like Sam Rockwell was there
而且这也像是，每当我记得阅读时，你知道的，在纽约，我们三个人进去试镜，现场大概有70个人。我们三个。你知道的，还记得吗？就像萨姆·罗克韦尔也在那里，
and, you know, Rick Gomez was there. And, you know, everybody was there. Josh Hamilton and... Thoreau using the office scissors there to tend to the sleeves. But you would go in and you would read with someone that might not be that great.
你知道的，瑞克·戈麦斯也在那里。而且，每个人都在那儿。乔什·汉密尔顿还有……梭罗正在那里用办公室的剪刀修理袖子。但你会走进去，和某个可能演技没那么好的人搭戏。
And so the instinct of an actor is to make that moment good. So you might do something completely different to what you planned. Right, because the other hand is clapping in a real weird way. It's just, right. That's a great point. So, wait, hey, well, while I got you there, let me ask you about that. Yeah, he's not going anywhere. Okay, great.
所以演员的本能就是要把那个时刻演好。所以你最终的表现可能会和你原本计划的完全不一样。没错，因为另一只手在以一种非常诡异的方式鼓掌。就是这样，对吧。这真是个绝妙的观点。所以，等等，嘿，好吧，趁我还抓着你，让我问你个问题。是的，他哪儿也不去。好吧，太棒了。
We got you for a little bit, right? Yeah. Well, I got you. But I was just talking to somebody about that. I don't want to get into bullshit actor weeds here. You know, you are a guy who clearly has many different pitches in his arsenal, and you can throw the ball a bunch of different ways, and I won't torture the metaphor,
我们还能留你一会儿，对吧？是的。好吧，既然我留住了你。我刚才正和某人聊起这个。我可不想在这里陷入那些无聊的演员行业老生常谈。你知道的，你显然是一个在武器库里拥有许多不同投球手法的家伙，你可以用好几种不同的方式把球投出去，我不会去折磨这个隐喻了，
but if you're working with an actor that is doing something wildly different than what you assumed the night before when you were running your lines and making your plan for how you're going to do the scene tomorrow, and you show up on set, and that other actor is doing it completely differently than one would assume, do you, are you okay with pivoting and taking a different angle on your character,
但如果你合作的演员表现出的演法，和你昨晚背台词、计划明天这场戏怎么演时预想的完全不同，当你出现在片场时，那个演员的演法和任何人预想的都完全大相径庭，你会……你能够接受临时应变，从你角色的另一个角度切入吗？
just as you said, to make that scene work. Because a lot of actors, I find they just, they don't or they're not able to or they don't want to. No, I think for sure, that's the fun part, isn't it? I mean... Well, not for some. For some, it's just like, what the fuck are they doing? You know, director, can I talk to you?
就像你说的，为了让那场戏效果更好。因为我发现很多演员，他们根本不会，或者做不到，或者根本不想这么做。不，我绝对觉得，这才是好玩的部分，不是吗？我是说……好吧，对某些人来说可不是。对某些人来说，就是：这特么在搞什么？你知道的，导演，我能跟你谈谈吗？
I tell young actors, I tell my daughter, it's like, look, just show up early, over-prepare, and don't be a dick. and overprepared the main thing. Right. You know, it's like, know it's so well that you can act with anybody. Yeah, that you can adjust with anybody
我总是告诉年轻演员，我告诉我女儿：听着，早点到片场，做足准备，别当个混蛋。准备充分才是最主要的。对。你知道的，就是把它背得滚瓜烂熟，这样你跟谁都能搭戏。对，你可以跟任何人打配合，
at any kind of, anything they throw at you, you can adjust, yeah. And in the end, it's just a show. It's just a show. That's true. But wait, but Steve, do you find that you've kind of on that thread, do you find that you've kind of changed the way you approach as you've gotten older? Do you work differently than you did when you were a young actor?
不管什么情况，别人抛给你什么，你都能调整适应，是的。说到底，这只是一场戏。这只是一场戏。确实如此。等等，不过史蒂夫，顺着这个话题，你发现随着自己年龄的增长，你对待表演的方式有所改变吗？你现在的工作方式和年轻时当演员的时候不一样了吗？
Is it kind of the same? No, not really. Yeah. No. I kind of do it. Yeah, I'm the same. I get, I still get really nervous, man. I get scared when I go to a gig.
还是说基本上没变？不，其实没有。是的。没有。我还是老样子。是的，我还是老样子。我还是会觉得很紧张，老兄。我去接通告的时候还是会害怕。
And, you know, I was nervous coming on here. I mean, you know. I'm nervous right now. Sean Hayes. Yeah, interviewer of the year. Yeah. Well, Sean, it's like he's snorting a Xanax right now. What, um, don't you find, do you remember the last time you weren't nervous for a part?
而且，你知道的，我来上节目时也很紧张。我的意思是，你知道的。我现在就很紧张。肖恩·海斯。是的，年度最佳采访者。好吧，肖恩，他现在就像是在吸赞安诺一样。什么，嗯，难道你不觉得，你还记得你上一次对一个角色不感到紧张是什么时候吗？
And do you remember that performance being not? that great because I certainly do. Like the few times I've not been nervous, I just don't think it's any good. I think nerves are a good component to performance. Yeah, no, I agree. I think that's, yeah, for sure. Yeah, I agree. Let me ask something, the Macaroni Art Production Company in Kentucky, is that what you said? Yeah. Well, there's a Kentucky office. Oh, there's a Kentucky office. Oh, I thought it was the only office. Well, no. Well, no. Come on. You know, it's your office is your computer. Yeah, no, for sure. I just didn't know, like, how you get,
你还记得那次表演不怎么好吗？因为我绝对记得。就像我那几次不紧张的经历，我都觉得演得不咋地。我认为紧张感是表演中一个很好的要素。是的，不，我同意。我觉得那是，是的，肯定的。是的，我同意。让我问个问题，位于肯塔基州的“通心粉艺术制作公司”，你是这么说的吗？对。哦，那儿有个肯塔基办公室。哦，有一个肯塔基办公室。哦，我还以为那是唯一的办公室呢。好吧，不。好吧，不。拜托。你知道的，你的办公室就是你的电脑。是的，不，肯定的。我只是不知道，像你这样的，
how is it you can accomplish all you want to accomplish from Kentucky for our... It's a lot of work going on in Kentucky. There is, actually. It's a state. Oh, there is. Oh, okay. Yeah, no, the film instead of years really good. There's a lot of work that came here.
你怎么能从肯塔基州完成所有你想完成的事情，为了我们的……肯塔基州有很多工作在进行。实际上，确实有。它是一个州。哦，确实有。哦，好吧。是的，不，那里的电影产业这些年真的很好。有很多工作都来到这里了。
Oh, okay. No, no, I think I know what he's driving at. It's like, it's obviously, you know, New York and L.A. are typically thought of as the centers of, of the entertainment. Access to people and, you know. Right. You find it easy to sort of work. remotely as it were.
哦，好吧。不，不，我想我明白他的意思了。这就像，很显然，你知道的，纽约和洛杉矶通常被认为是娱乐业的中心。人脉资源和，你知道的。对。你觉得异地办公——姑且这么说吧——对你来说很容易吗？
Yeah, but, you know, we have a feature that's out in the zeitgeist now called She Dance as we shot it here. Yeah. And Rick Gomez is my partner. We wrote it. He directed it. I starred in it. My daughter stars in it.
是的，但是，你知道的，我们现在有一部在文化界挺火的剧情长片叫《她跳舞》，我们就是在这里拍的。是的。瑞克·戈麦斯是我的合伙人。我们一起写的剧本。他执导的。我主演的。我女儿主演的。
Nice. We shot it all here. And by shooting it here, we saved so much money, man. I'm sure. Yeah. Did they have one of those rebates there in that state? Yeah, we have a 30% and then 35% outside. And is it above or?
太棒了。我们全是在这里拍的。而且通过在这里拍摄，我们省了好多钱，老兄。我敢肯定。是的。那个州有某种退税政策吗？是的，我们有30%的退税，如果在特定地区外还有35%。那是高于还是？
above and below the line or is it just below the line? Just below the line. So tell Tracy what below and above the line. Well, the line is drawn between the, well, the above the line is typically the director, the producer, the writer, the actors, and then below the line is the everybody that works in the crew and post-production and all that stuff. Don't quote me on that. I think, I don't know.
是“线上”还是“线下”，还是仅仅指“线下”？仅仅是指“线下”。所以给特蕾西解释一下什么是“线上”和“线下”。好吧，分界线画在……好吧，“线上”通常指导演、制片人、编剧、演员，而“线下”则是指所有在剧组工作的人、后期制作以及所有这些东西。别拿我的话当权威。我想，我也不知道。
Look it up. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Got it. binding on this podcast. But talk to me about Kentucky in general, though. Like, what do you, how did you find yourself? How did you move from Pennsylvania down to Kentucky? I've been coming here since, my wife grew up here.
自己去查吧。对，对，对。明白了。在这个播客上不具法律效力。不过，跟我聊聊肯塔基州本身吧。比如，你是怎么，你是怎么发现自己的？你是怎么从宾夕法尼亚搬到肯塔基州的？我从……我妻子在这里长大，所以我一直来这里。
Okay. So I've been coming here since 90, and I've loved Kentucky. And then we had kids, and we lived on a farm in New Jersey, West Central, New Jersey. And there's not a lot out there, you know. I mean, we kept saying, like, we're only an hour from the Met. Is that near Somerset? It was Delaware Water Gap.
好的。所以我从90年代就开始来了，我一直很喜欢肯塔基州。然后我们有了孩子，我们住在新泽西州的一个农场里，新泽西州中西部。那里其实没多少人烟，你知道的。我的意思是，我们一直说，比如，我们离大都会歌剧院只有一小时车程。那是在萨默塞特附近吗？那是特拉华水峡。
You know where 80 hits Pennsylvania? Yep. Yep. It's like Blairstown area. Eastern Pennsylvania is close by. Is it my right? Yeah. The Poconos, Straussburg.
你知道80号公路通往宾夕法尼亚哪里吗？Yep. Yep. 就像布莱尔斯敦一带。宾夕法尼亚州东部就在附近。我没说错吧？是的。波科诺斯，斯特劳斯堡。
You'd go directly, directly west from the city. GW straight out. And so we had kids, and it was like, I don't know if this was great out here for kids. Because why? Because it was too isolating? Yeah, there was not a lot of. out there. And so we decided, you know, I said, why don't we move to, you know, outside Lexington?
你从城里直接往西走。沿着华盛顿大桥直走。然后我们有了孩子，就觉得，不知道这里对小孩子来说是不是个好地方。因为为什么？因为太与世隔绝了吗？是的，外面没多少……人烟。所以我们决定，你知道的，我说：“我们为什么不搬到，你知道的，列克星敦郊外去呢？”
And my wife, of course, was like, I'm not moving home. I'm like, well, I'm not living in your parents' basement. We're going to get a sweet place. Right, right, right. And you went ahead and you did. And the kids love it? Yeah, the kids grew up here. They know nothing other than this place. And how old are these little angels? 26 and 24. Oh, gosh. Oh, gosh. Oh, wow. Yeah, they're out of your back. Wait a second. Steve, does Rick live in Kentucky as well? No, Gomez lives up in Healdsburg in Sonoma County. Oh, wow.
我妻子当然是那种“我才不搬回家”的态度。我说：“好吧，我可不住在你父母的地下室。我们要找个很棒的地方。”对，对，对。然后你去了，而且你真的做到了。孩子们喜欢那里吗？是的，孩子们是在这里长大的。除了这个地方，他们对外面的世界一无所知。那这些小天使多大了？26岁和24岁。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，哇。是的，他们已经不用你操心了。等等。史蒂夫，瑞克也住在肯塔基州吗？不，戈麦斯住在索诺玛县的希尔兹堡。哦，哇。
And we've shot stuff up there, too. That's California. I love that. That town is awesome. I haven't seen that dude. I used to know that dude 30 years ago. He's the best guy. He's great.
我们在那边也拍过东西。那是加利福尼亚州。我太喜欢那里了。那个小镇棒极了。我好久没见那家伙了。我30年前就认识那家伙了。他是最好的人。他棒极了。
I haven't seen him in forever. Please add him for me. I will for sure. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What was it like working with your daughter in the film? It was amazing.
我好久没见他了。请替我向他问好。我一定会的。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。和你的女儿一起拍电影是什么感觉？太棒了。
Yeah? She's been acting a while, or was just the first thing? Audrey went to musical theater a great school called Baldwin Wallace. Sean, you probably know about that. But it's one of those, they didn't have these schools when we were young. It's very specific to musical theater. She was there two years, and then she started working in theater, musical theater. So she's got a great voice, I bet.
是吗？她演戏有一段时间了，还是说这只是第一部作品？奥黛丽读的是音乐剧专业，那是一所叫鲍德温华莱士的优秀学校。肖恩，你可能知道。但那是那种学校，我们年轻时可没有这种学校。它是非常专注于音乐剧的。她在那里读了两年，然后她开始从事戏剧、音乐剧工作。所以我敢打赌她有一副好嗓子。
She's got a great voice. She's an amazing dancer. and even better actor. Had you guys worked together before? No. And will you work together again, or is that it, did it end okay? Bridges Byrne? Yeah, no, it was the best thing in it.
她有一副好嗓子。她是个出色的舞者，而且是个更好的演员。你们以前一起合作过吗？没有。你们以后还会合作吗？还是说就这样了，合作得还愉快吗？桥梁伯恩？（译者注：此处史蒂夫可能在玩梗或口误，结合语境意指合作非常顺利）是的，不，那是里面最好的部分。
I mean, it was like working on any other movie for me. Right. And that's a compliment to her. It's got to be wild, though, to adjust your brain to, to like, dad to then coworker, right? Yeah. Like, kind of, but I don't know. No?
我的意思是，对我来说，这就跟拍其他任何电影一样。没错。这也是对她的赞美。不过，要把你的大脑从“父亲”切换到“同事”，这种感觉一定很疯狂吧？是的。有点像，但我不知道。不是吗？
It was, we worked on it so much. We read, I was doing Silo, and she came to visit for like a month. And we read every day. And so we knew it back and forth, you know. But you didn't have any moments on set where they were cut and you were like, hey, are you going to do it like that every time? Because, you know, we're rolling, right? You know, yeah.
我们为这部电影排练了太多次了。我们读剧本……当时我在拍《末日地堡》，她来探班大约一个月。我们每天都在读剧本。所以我们对剧本烂熟于心，你知道的。但在片场有没有那么几个瞬间，导演喊卡之后，你心里想：“嘿，你每次都要这么演吗？因为，你知道的，我们在拍呢，对吧？”你知道的，是的。
No. Okay. I mean, see the movie. It's, you know, I'm her dad, so I'm going to say great things. But I can't wait for days. She's phenomenal. When does that come out? Is it, uh...
没有。好吧。我的意思是，去看这部电影吧。它是，你知道的，我是她老爸，所以我肯定会说好话。但我迫不及待了。她太惊艳了。那部电影什么时候上映？是，呃……
It's, it's been out, it premiered at Tribeca. It's now, you can, you can rent it or buy it on, you know, you're... Okay, gotcha. And then it... Forget red, buy it. Buy it. And then, and then it comes out on Peacock on the 21st. Gotcha.
它，它已经上映了，在翠贝卡电影节首映的。现在你可以，你可以在网上，你知道的... 好了，明白了。然后它... 别管红的了，买它。买它。然后，然后它在21号在Peacock上线。明白了。
Wow. Amazing. Uh, wait, so, Steve, you grew up in, uh, Minnesota. Yeah. In the Twin Cities region? I love hearing the train in the background. I was, so... Do you hear that train?
哇。太棒了。呃，等等，所以，史蒂夫，你是在，呃，明尼苏达州长大的。是的。在双城地区？我喜欢听背景里的火车声。我当时... 你听到那列火车了吗？
Is that fake? Yeah, it's great. No, it's literally, it's going to go by, and it's like 40 feet away. You pointed at you? Yeah. Oh, boy. Oh, wow.
那是假的吗？是的，太棒了。不，它是真的，它就要开过去了，距离大概只有40英尺。它指着你？是的。哦，天哪。哦，哇。
Hey, Steve, you want to call us back. Oh, buddy. There goes the train. That's cool. It's really cool. It splits Main Street. It's, you know, it goes down the middle. It'd be great if we pan the camera
嘿，史蒂夫，你想给我们回个电话。哦，老兄。火车开过去了。太酷了。真的很酷。它把主街分成了两半。它，你知道的，从中间穿过。如果我们把镜头摇过去
and it was just some dude who works for you walking by it with a speaker. Yeah. And walk by. Now, growing up in Minnesota, that probably makes you a hockey fan. Yeah, yeah, I dig the hockey. I had two friends that played pro. No kidding. Will would like to know their names.
然后发现只是一个为你工作的家伙拿着扬声器从旁边走过。是的。然后走过去。话说在明尼苏达州长大，你可能因此成了个冰球迷。对，对，我很喜欢冰球。我有两个朋友打过职业联赛。不是吧。威尔想知道他们的名字。
Dennis Vasky. Oh, sure. And Lance Pitlick. Lance was a defensiveman. You know, Lance played for Ottawa. He played for a lot of teams. I don't know. Oh, he's not right.
丹尼斯·瓦斯基。哦，当然。还有兰斯·皮特里克。兰斯是个防守队员。你知道，兰斯为渥太华效力过。他为很多球队效力过。我不知道。哦，他不对。
Oh, good. He was our quarterback in football at my high school. And then he went on ahead. And then became a... I know. These athletes, they can do anything they want, you know. And they can go out there and you put a golf club in their hands and off the go. Those guys were insane, man.
哦，太好了。他是我高中的美式橄榄球四分卫。然后他继续前行。然后成为了一名... 我知道。这些运动员，他们想做什么就能做什么，你知道的。他们可以走到那里，你把一根高尔夫球杆塞进他们手里，他们就出发了。那些家伙太疯狂了，老兄。
They would shoot pucks every day. Yeah. Winter, summer, fall, spring, it didn't matter. And I was the guy who had the... We made, you know, goalie pads out of, like, an old couch. Yeah. And I would just suffer. in front of, you know.
他们每天都练习射门。对。冬天、夏天、秋天、春天，都一样。而我就是那个拿着... 我们用旧沙发做，你知道的，守门员护具。对。我就会在，你知道的，前面饱受折磨。
No, Steve. Yeah. We, I used to drive through, I spent all my summers on Lake of the Woods that dips into Minnesota up there. Yeah, yeah. Because my whole family's from Winnipeg, Manitoba. So I used to spend a lot of,
不，史蒂夫。对。我们，我以前经常开车穿过，我所有的夏天都在伍兹湖度过，那片湖延伸到了明尼苏达州北部。对，对。因为我的全家都来自马尼托巴省温尼伯。所以我以前经常花很多时间，
and we would drive through Minnesota to get there. Oh, yeah, it's cool. It's beautiful, man. It's beautiful country out there. Do you get back to Minnesota at all? Yeah, yeah, I was just back visiting my mom. How did you, so then, how, was it Twin Cities area,
我们会开车穿过明尼苏达州去那里。哦，对，这很酷。太棒了，老兄。那里的风景美极了。你还会回明尼苏达州吗？对，对，我刚刚回去看望了我妈妈。那么你是怎么，然后，怎么，是双城地区吗，
though, that you grew up? I grew up. I was born in Marshall. I grew up in Mancato, which is a smaller town south. And then I moved during like junior high school up to the suburbs. You know, I was a suburban kid. And did you, so, and then how did you, because you started acting professionally pretty young, like you're like 20s, right? Like early 20s?
虽然你在那里长大？我长大的。我出生在马歇尔。我在曼卡托长大，那是南边的一个小镇。然后我在初中左右搬到了郊区。你知道，我曾经是个郊区小孩。那你，然后，你是怎么，因为你很年轻就开始进行专业表演了，比如你20多岁，对吧？大概20岁出头？
Yeah. You were getting work. I was doing theater. How old were you when you did reality bites? Like you weren't that old. That was, I was, I had moved to New York. I'd been in New York for like three years. Okay.
对。你一直在接工作。我当时在演戏剧。你拍《现实的bite》时多大？你当时没那么老。那是，我搬到了纽约。我在纽约待了大约三年。好吧。
And then I got that. Did you audition for that for Reality Bites? I did. You did? I was doing a play with Ethan Hawke at Playwrights Horizons. Oh, nice. And a play called Sophistry. Yes.
然后我得到了那个角色。你为《现实的bite》试镜了吗？我试过。真的吗？我当时在剧作家地平线剧场和伊桑·霍克一起演一出戏。哦，不错。一出叫《诡辩》的戏。是的。
Sean? I don't know that. I don't know. I do. That was a great cast. It was like Anthony Ramp and Callista Flockhart. Wow. When was that?
肖恩？我不知道那个。我不知道。我知道。那是个很棒的演员阵容。有安东尼·拉普和卡莉斯塔·弗洛克哈特。哇。那是什么时候？
Dick Letessa. Dick Letessa was in Promises Promises with me. Oh, great. Dick was one of the greatest greatest guys of all time. I mean, he was like 90 when he was in Promises, Promises.
迪克·莱特萨。迪克·莱特萨和我一起演过《承诺，承诺》。哦，太棒了。迪克是有史以来最伟大、最伟大的人之一。我的意思是，他在演《承诺，承诺》时大概90岁了。
I was like, how are you singing and dancing at 90 years? It was amazing show. Anyway, Ben came to see Ethan in the show because he was, you know, directing him in reality bites, and then I auditioned and I got the part. That's so cool.
我当时想，你怎么能在90岁的时候又唱又跳？这是一场精彩的演出。不管怎样，本来看伊桑的演出，因为他，你知道的，在《现实的bite》里指导他，然后我去试镜，就得到了这个角色。太酷了。
Was that a sort of a bit of a career changer doing reality bites? Yeah, I thought it was going to be much more of a career changer. You know, it's like your first movies, you go do them and you come home and you're like poorer than you were. Like, how is that possible? Yeah, right. You pay to do it. Right.
拍《现实的bite》算是改变了你的职业生涯吗？是的，我以为它会对我的职业生涯产生更大的改变。你知道，就像你的第一部电影，你去拍了，然后你回家，结果发现自己比以前更穷了。这怎么可能？对，没错。你还得倒贴钱去演。对。
What's been the opposite in your career? Do you think, like something you thought was just going to be a, not a stinker, but it's success surprised you? I would say, you know, like, I mean, a whole lot. I mean, I'm always surprised. I think. Yeah. You know? And then sometimes, I mean,
在你职业生涯中，什么是相反的情况？你觉得，就像有些你以为只是个，不是烂片，但它的成功却让你感到惊讶？我会说，你知道的，比如，很多。我的意思是，我总是感到惊讶。我觉的。你知道吗？然后有时候，我的意思是，
comedies, you laugh your ass off on set and then you go see it, you're like, yeah, it wasn't as funny as it was on the day. Yeah. I'm going to do Will's shop here.
喜剧，你在片场笑得前仰后合，然后去看成片，你会觉得，好吧，其实没那么好笑。好吧。我要在这里聊聊威尔的店。
You can't blame the editor on that. Oh, no, I can't guess what he's thinking about. And I'm not going to name movies. Let's look. Phineas and Ferb. What about... Out of sight.
你不能把这怪到剪辑师头上。哦，不，我猜不到他在想什么。我不会点名电影。我们来看看。飞哥与小佛。怎么样……战略高手。
Night train. Out of sight. You know what? I was really surprised. When I saw Out of sight for the first time, I blew me away. And I had no clue I was in that movie.
夺命煞星。战略高手。你知道吗？我真的很吃惊。当我第一次看《战略高手》时，它把我震撼到了。而我根本不知道我在那部电影里。
No, I was, I was, I remember Cheatel sitting in front of me, he was like, isn't it great? I'm like, I haven't seen it, man. This was like the premiere. He's like, you haven't seen it? I'm like, no, he's like, oh, man. And he, like, he watched me react to the movie. Yeah. It was like, it was really cool.
不，我，我，我记得切钱特坐在我前面，他说，这不是很棒吗？我说，我还没看呢，老兄。这就像是首映式。他说，你还没看？我说，没有，他说，哦，天哪。然后他，就像，他看着我对这部电影的反应。是的。这感觉，真的很酷。
But like Will said, that thing you do, that was a pretty big career Turner. That was huge for me. Yeah. It was all, it was that Tom, Tom Hanks directed that, right? Yeah. Was that his first thing that he directed?
但正如威尔所说，那部《挡不住的奇迹》，那是一个相当大的转折点。这对我很重要。是的。都是，那是汤姆，汤姆·汉克斯导演的，对吧？是的。那是他导演的第一部作品吗？
Yeah. Was it? I think he directed maybe an episode of like from Earth to the Moon, like that HBO series. And three bosom buddies. Yeah, maybe. But yeah, that was crazy because Tom was at the height of the height of, you know,
是的。是吗？我想他可能导演过类似HBO系列剧《从地球到月球》的一集。还有三个哥们。是的，也许吧。但是是的，这太疯狂了，因为汤姆当时正处于，你知道的，人生巅峰，
and everybody that worked on that movie was like phenomenal. Yeah. Was that, I did, I missed it. Was it singing and dancing? No, it was about a 1960s rock band. It was like a one-hit wonder. Yeah, it was a great movie. Was there any musical performance at all in that that you guys had?
每个参与那部电影的人都太优秀了。是的。那是，我没赶上。那是又唱又跳吗？不，那是关于一个1960年代的摇滚乐队。就像是一夜成名的乐队。是的，这是一部好电影。里面有什么音乐表演是你们参与的吗？
Yeah, we played a bunch of songs. We rehearsed. And the song, that thing you do. That thing you do. Right, so, same and dancing. J.B, you've never seen it. No. It's good.
对，我们弹奏了一堆歌曲。我们排练了。还有那首歌，《挡不住的奇迹》。《挡不住的奇迹》。对，所以，又唱又跳。J.B，你从来没看过。没有。很好看。
You should see it. It's one of those movies that people come up to me and go, you know, it's like Thanksgiving. My family watches it every year kind of. thing. It's had this super long shelf life. It's funny that movie, right? I mean, it's... Yeah. Did you have to fake the music playing, or do you know how to do that stuff? Well, we were...
你应该去看看。那是那种人们会走过来对我说，你知道的，就像感恩节一样。我的家人每年都会看那种电影。它的生命力太长了。那部电影很有趣，对吧？我的意思是，它是……是的。你得假装弹奏音乐吗，还是你知道怎么做？好吧，我们……
That was crazy because Tom and Gary Getsman had his rehearse for like a month just as a band. Yeah. Because they didn't want to waste time, not us screwing up and not being on. So we had to... Seems reasonable.
那太疯狂了，因为汤姆和加里·戈茨曼让我们作为乐队排练了一个月左右。是的。因为他们不想浪费时间，不想让我们搞砸而不在状态。所以我们必须……听起来很合理。
Yeah. And, you know, when you're back in the day on film and big shots. What instrument were you playing? Lead guitar. Oh, shit. Whoa. And did you have prior experience?
是的。而且，你知道的，过去在胶片时代和拍大片的时候。你当时在弹什么乐器？主音吉他。哦，操。哇。那你之前有经验吗？
Yeah, but I was just like a a fokey kind of, you know, acoustic guy. But you had a rock guy. Actually, Ben Stiller bought me my first guitar. Did he? Oh, wow. Just because?
行吧，但我以前大概是个民谣风的、你知道的，那种弹原声吉他的家伙。但你是个摇滚范的。其实，本·斯蒂勒给我买了我的第一把吉他。是吗？哦，哇。就凭空送的？
Oh, reality bites. Because, you know, I would sit in my trailer all day and he was like, that was really nice. And once you learn how to play guitar. We keep calling him in early and not get into his scene. So let's buy.
哦，因为《现实的创伤》。因为，你知道的，我整天都坐在我的房车里，然后他就觉得，那挺不错的。一旦你学会了弹吉他。我们就会一直早早地叫他过去，结果却不用拍他的戏。所以我们就买吧。
a kid, a guitar. Hey, Zion, what'd you do something with your freaking time, okay? Well, you're sitting in your honey wagon. Hey, think about it back then, though. It's like, you tell people now, you have all these devices and things to keep you preoccupied.
一个小孩，一把吉他。嘿，齐恩，你能不能用你那该死的时间做点什么，行吗？好吧，当你坐在你的化妆车里的时候。嘿，回想一下当年吧。这就好比，你现在告诉别人，你有各种各样的设备和东西来打发时间。
Back in the day, man. You're like, I would, like, draw and stuff. Yeah, read books. Yeah. I'd take a nap. I used to be good about reading books back then. Oh. Oh, Sean's got a train.
想当年啊，老兄。你会觉得，我会画画什么的。对，看书。对。我会小睡一会儿。我过去那会儿很擅长看书。哦。哦，肖恩有个火车玩具。
Hey. that didn't take more than 15 minutes to find That's where Sean's been Congrats Johnny How's that dial-up service? Wait, but you know, I mentioned I'm thinking about like out of sight Like, you know, that
嘿。这找起来可没花超过15分钟呢。肖恩刚才就去那儿了。恭喜啊，强尼。你那拨号上网服务怎么样？等等，不过你知道的，我提到过我正在想像是《战略高手》那种。
You did with Stephen Soderberg And obviously Clooney And then you've worked with so many You've worked with so many You were Denzel Washington writing in Crimson Tide I mentioned Tony Scott And then I was thinking about Werzerzog and...
你和史蒂芬·索德伯格合作的那部。很明显还有克鲁尼。然后你合作过那么多。你合作过那么多。你在《赤潮》里给丹泽尔·华盛顿配戏。我提到了托尼·斯科特。然后我就想到了赫尔佐格和……
I was going to say Werner Herzog. Herzog was... Richard Linklater. Rescue Don, right? Yeah. Yeah, what was it like working with... I've always wanted to ask people. What was Don's last name?
我本来想说韦纳·赫尔佐格。赫尔佐格是……理查德·林克莱特。《抢救唐》对吧？对。Yeah，和……合作是什么感觉？我一直想问别人。唐的姓是什么？
What? No, it's not about rescuing a girl named Don. Oh. I thought she was in trouble. Or he could have been in trouble. Or Don. Yeah, no. Old Donnie.
什么？不，这不是关于营救一个叫唐的女孩。哦。我还以为她遇到麻烦了呢。或者他当时可能遇到麻烦了。或者叫唐。对，没有。老唐尼。
But it was you and Chris... Right, Christian Bail, rescued Don. And what was that process like working with? How did that movie materialize? It was originally a documentary that Dead Werner made called Little Deeter Needs to Fly about this real Dieter Dengler who was a Navy pilot. His first mission over Vietnam was shot down. Sean's got the cutest little Dieter Dangler.
但那是你和克里斯……对，克里斯蒂安·贝尔，营救唐。那个合作过程是怎样的？那部电影是怎么筹备起来的？它最初是死去的韦纳拍的一部纪录片，叫做《重返危机》，讲的是这个真实的迪特·丹格勒，他是一个海军飞行员。他在越南上空的第一次任务就被击落了。肖恩有个最可爱的“小迪特·丹格勒”。
I'm going to post it later, especially when he's getting in line for a cold shower. Cold shower, sure. Anyway, he gets captured And then he's in this camp And so it was a really, you know It was a really heavy movie And we lost all this weight And, you know, went off into the jungle
我等会儿要把它发出来，尤其是当他在排队洗冷水澡的时候。冷水澡，确实。总之，他被俘虏了。然后他被关在这个集中营里。所以那真的是一部，你知道的。那真的是一部很沉重的电影。我们减了所有的体重。然后，你知道的，就一头扎进了丛林。
But did Werner Hertzsock Was that another one you went in? You read for it, right? I found out that he was doing it And I just told, you know, I called on my people And we're like, I have to meet, I have to meet him.
但是韦纳·赫尔佐格？这也是你亲自去的那部吗？你为它试镜了，对吧？我发现他在筹备这个项目，然后我直接就，你知道的，我给我的团队打电话，我们当时就说，我必须去见他，我必须见他。
This is one of my favorite documentaries And so I met him. I went to his house up in like the hills and he wanted to know what I wanted to eat. And I was like, oh, what do I say to impress him? You know, I was like, steak. And so he went, he cooked me a steak.
这是我最喜欢的纪录片之一。于是我见到了他。我去了他在山上的房子，他想知道我想吃什么。然后我就想，哦，我说什么才能给他留下深刻印象呢？你知道的，我就说，牛排。于是他去了，他给我煎了一块牛排。
He's just so good at his skillet. And he was, and he showed me, oh, it was crazy. We had this night. Did he eat two? Did he eat two or he watched you as watch? Yeah, no. No, we shared a steak. Okay, okay.
他用平底锅的手艺真是太棒了。而且他，他还向我展示了，哦，太疯狂了。我们度过了这样一个夜晚。他吃两块吗？他自己吃两块还是看着你吃？对，没有。不，我们俩分了一块牛排。好吧，好吧。
And then, oh, wait a second. He shared the same plate. I can't remember specifically, but it was very. I mean, was he tarps off or was you wearing a shirt? See, Steve, we bring everything back around. So you keep your knees bent, okay? Okay. Oh, my God.
然后，哦，等一下。他用的是同一个盘子。我记不清具体细节了，但非常……我是说，他当时赤膊上阵还是穿着衬衫？看吧，史蒂夫，我们把话题又绕回来了。所以你得把膝盖弯曲，好吗？好吧。噢，天哪。
Yeah. Wow, wait, so you were, so you go up to, I want to know about this. So you go to Werner Herzog's house that he's probably renting in the hills in California. Yeah. You're talking about the movie. Then you agree, and you guys,
对。哇，等等，所以你当时是，所以你去了，我想了解一下这个。所以你去了韦纳·赫尔佐格在加州山上的房子，那可能租的吧。对。你们在聊电影的事。然后你们达成了共识，然后你们……
he wants you to come and do the movie, or you read from, you don't read from that day. He was like, Steve, I think you're better to play not the lead part. but the other part, you know, I'm like, great, fine. I'll play fucking anything. I don't care. Not so much to eater.
他希望你来拍这部电影，或者你试读了剧本，你那天没有试读剧本。他当时说，史蒂夫，我觉得你更适合演那个不是主角的配角，而是另一个角色，你知道的，我说，太好了，没问题。我他妈演什么都行。我不在乎。不是演迪特。
Yeah. Yeah, not, yeah. So, and then it went on forever. It was like, you know, one of those independent movies that fell apart and the Christian would call me and go, eat tonight. I don't think the movie's happening. I was like, fuck. And then it'd be like, stop, stop eating.
对。对，不是，对。所以，然后这事就没完没了了。这就好像是，你知道的，那种最终黄了的独立电影，然后克里斯就会打电话给我说，今晚吃吧。我觉得这电影拍不成了。我当时就想，操。然后就会变成，停，别吃了。
It's back on. And, and, and it was phenomenal. It was amazing. It was, I mean, Vernor's, is genius. He's also the guy on the set where you're like, what's happening? And then like a fucking butterfly will fly through, and he in the operator just run off into the woods,
项目又复活了。而且，而且，这太不可思议了。太惊人了。我是说，韦纳的才华简直是天才。他也是那种在片场会让你觉得，这到底在发生什么呢？然后突然一只他妈的蝴蝶飞了过去，他和摄影师就直接一起跑进树林里了，
and you're like three hours late. Oh, one time I was in my coveralls and I get grazed with a bullet, and he was like screaming at hair makeup, more blood, boy! He was like, let me do it! And he grabs it. And he puts up all this blood on my face.
然后你们就得晚三个小时。哦，有一次我穿着连体工作服，被一颗子弹擦伤了，然后他冲着发型化妆组大喊，多点血，小伙子！他当时喊道，让我来！然后他一把抓过来。把那些血全抹在我脸上。
and then his hands are covered in blood, fake blood, and he doesn't know what to do. He just looks at me, and he wipes it off on my costume. No way. swear to God. That's cool. Yeah, it was awesome. Wow. Wow.
然后他的手上沾满了血，假血，结果他不知道该怎么办了。他就看着我，然后直接把血抹在我的戏服上。不可能。我发誓对上帝。太酷了。对，太棒了。哇。哇。
And Christian was one of the funniest guys that ever worked with, by the way. Really? Christian Bail, yeah. Oh, my God. I'm such a big fan of his. He's so. Yeah, me too. Great and funny.
顺便说一句，克里斯是我合作过最搞笑的人之一。真的吗？克里斯蒂安·贝尔，对。哦，天哪。我是他的超级粉丝。他太……对，我也是。又棒又搞笑。
So talented. Would you do any of that weight gain, weight loss stuff that he does so sort of seamlessly? I mean, what was it, the machinist? Machinist. He went down to look like 120 pounds. You should know, Steve, Jason had a picture of Christian and the machinist on his wall in front of his treadmill. For years, for years.
太有才了。你会做那种他那种似乎轻而易举就能做到的增重、减重的事情吗？我是说，那是什么来着，机械师？《机械师》。他体重暴跌到大概120磅。你可能不知道，史蒂夫，杰森的跑步机正前方的墙上就贴着一张克里斯在《机械师》里的照片。好多年了，好多年了。
And he just looked at his goal. As his running towards it. Never worked. Never worked. And then I put up a picture of when he, what was it, when he played Dick Cheney. That worked. That worked for me.
他看着那个目标。就像在向它奔跑一样。从来没管用过。从来没管用过。然后我贴了一张他演，那是啥来着，他扮演迪克·切尼时的照片。那个管用了。那个对我管用。
You thought it was that. It turned out it was a mirror. You thought. No, he put on a ton for that, right? I just don't think I can do it at this age. Yeah, he lost a lot of weight. We shot the end of the movie first. So he lost all the weight.
你以为那是。结果发现那是面镜子。你以为。不，他为了那个角色增肥了很多，对吧？我只是觉得我这个年纪做不到了。对，他减了很多体重。我们先拍了电影的结局。所以他把体重都减掉了。
And then he had like a week. I'm wearing Thailand. And I remember seeing him on the street. And he was walking up and he had quarter-pounders in his pockets. No, really. And his cargo pants. I swear to God, he was. With cheese?
然后他在泰国大概呆了一个星期。我记得在街上看到他。他正朝这边走来，口袋里装着巨无霸汉堡。不，真的。在他的工装裤口袋里。我发誓上帝，他当时就是。加芝士的？
He was gaining... Careful, Sean. Cating weight in like a week. Sounds amazing. Wow. Getting all puffy and a lot of sodium. How about that? Yeah.
他在增加……小心点，肖恩。在一周左右的时间里疯狂增重。听起来太惊人了。哇。变得肿胀不堪，摄入了大量钠。怎么样？对。
I don't think... Playing the hamburger. I only did. I lost 40 pounds for that. And you know what? Oh, my God. Yeah. And you know what was really liberating?
我不认为……扮演那个汉堡。我只做过这个。我为了那个角色减了40磅。你知道吗？哦，天哪。对。你知道什么才是真正的解放吗？
It's, um, I lost, I was down to like, you know, whatever junior high weight. And I still had back fat. Yeah. Uh-huh. That's a hard stuff to lose, you know. You know, it's, but it was like, oh great this will never go away unless I'm in like a lifeboat right you know for a month I feel like the back fat is for you know like on the old like
就是，嗯，我减了，我的体重降到了，你知道的，大概初中时候的体重。但我依然有后腰赘肉。对。嗯哼。那是很难减掉的东西，你知道的。你知道的，这就像是，哦太棒了，这玩意儿永远都不会消失，除非我坐在救生艇里，对吧，你知道的，待上一个月。我觉得后腰赘肉就是为了，你知道的，就像老一辈的那种……
uh I love this you've got a point of view on back yeah let me give you a hot take on this you know the belts the little vibrating belts and the old timey stuff right yeah yeah yeah is that what those are for they just shake it till it falls off yeah maybe I don't understand how those work yeah I understand what made you think of that that I know exactly the conveyor belt thing or the yeah right it's just all backfracts yeah yeah yeah what does it I have a friend of mine who played professional hockey, who will remain nameless. Deion Phineuf.
呃，我喜欢这个，你对后背有看法，对。让我对这个发表个犀利见解，你知道的，那些腰带，那种微型振动腰带和老式的那种东西，对吧，对，对，对。那些东西是干嘛用的？它们就是不停地抖，直到肉掉下来，对吧，也许吧。我不明白那些是怎么运作的。对，我明白是什么让你想起那个的，我太清楚那个传送带似的东西或者那个了，对吧，那全都是后腰赘肉，对吧，对吧，那是干什么的？我有个朋友打过职业冰球，我就不点名了。迪昂·菲诺夫。
He played for many years. And I won't say who. And he talked about being in a fight. Friend is Shian. True story. He was in a fight. It's got to be Shannie. It's got to be Shannie.
他打了好多年。而我不会说是谁。他谈到了打架的事。朋友是香尼。真实的故事。他打过架。那肯定是香尼。那绝对是香尼。
Yeah, I know you can't confirm her tonight. But so Shanny's doing what? So not Shanny. I'm going to say, not Shany. Okay. Sean Avery. Huge fight in the NHL. And there's a big pile up.
对，我知道你今晚不能确认。但所以香尼在做什么？所以不是香尼。我要说，不是香尼。好吧。肖恩·阿韦里。在NHL打过超级大架。然后一大堆人扭打在一起。
There's a real Donnybrook is happening, right? everybody's going at everybody. Tarps are coming off. Tarps are coming off, eh? Like, guys, everybody's dropped the coopers. You're just going out there. Yeah, right? Yeah, just a real tune-up going.
真的爆发了一场唐尼布鲁克式的大混战，对吧？所有人都冲向所有人。球衣都被扒下来了。球衣都被扒下来了，是吧？就像，伙计们，所有人都扔下了冰球棍。你们就直接冲上去了。对吧？对，就是一场真正的群殴在进行。
And there's a big pile, and my friend said he, at one point, he didn't realize who's grabbing what, and he realized there was another guy in the pile, and he had his hand on his back fat, and he just grabbed it and twisted it, and he said he heard from the bottom of the pile, a scream. Not the fat.
然后有一堆人叠罗汉，我朋友说他，有一刻，他根本没意识到谁在抓着谁，然后他意识到人群堆里还有另一个人，他的手正抓着对方的后腰赘肉，然后他一把抓住并狠狠地拧了一下，他说他听到人群堆的最底部传了一声惨叫。不是那块肥肉。
They should teach that in self-defense classes. And they ended up calling, they all gave him the nickname Backfat after that, the dude on the opposing team. I swear to God, it's a true story. It's a cheap shot. It really is. Dennis Vaski, my friend who played pro hockey, he woke me out. I slept over at his house and he woke me up doing a double titty twister.
他们应该在自卫课上教这个。最后他们干脆给那个对手起绰号叫“后腰赘肉”了。我发誓，这是个真实的故事。这太阴损了。真的。丹尼斯·瓦斯基，我那个打过职业冰球的朋友，他弄醒了我。我在他家过夜，他用一记“双重胸部拧转”把我弄醒了。
Oh, God. And he was a hockey player. Painful. I don't know what it is. They're such tough, dude. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Wait, what sports have you played, Steve?
哦，天哪。而且他还是个冰球运动员。太痛苦了。我不知道这是为什么。他们这群硬汉，真是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。等等，史蒂夫，你打过什么运动？
Football and baseball. Oh, you did, yeah. Full stop. That's that. Now, does that make you a Viking fan or a twin fan? I'm a Vikings fan and a twin fan. Oh, boy. Yeah.
橄榄球和棒球。哦，你打过，对。句号。就这些。那这让你成了维京人队的球迷还是双城队的球迷？我是维京人队的球迷和双城队的球迷。哦，天哪。对。
So the twins, that's a tough bus to ride on. Cool it, Jason. No, not really. I mean, they're doing good this year. Are they? But we had 87 and 91. You know, oh boy, look at them, reach back. I know, it's pretty far back.
所以双城队，那可是一条很难熬的公交路线啊。冷静点，杰森。不，其实还好。我是说，他们今年表现不错。是吗？但我们有87年和91年的辉煌。你知道的，哦天哪，你看他们，回忆过去了。我知道，这确实挺遥远的。
Back when they used to playing the big baggie, right? Wait a second. I'm remembering... Curvy Pucket. 87, you guys beat... Is that that old Dome Stadium and you got... Yeah. It was a great series.
回到他们还在大穹顶体育场打球的时代，对吧？等一下。我记起来了……柯比·帕克特。87年，你们击败了……是那个老穹顶体育场然后你们……对。那真是一个伟大的系列赛。
They were probably beating up on Toronto right now. No, because they're... No. No, in the World Series, it was not Toronto. It was... It was... In 87, might have been the Giants. Do you want me to say?
他们现在可能正在痛扁多伦多队吧。不对，因为他们是……不对。不对，在世界大赛上，对手不是多伦多。是……是……在87年，可能是巨人队？你想让我说吗？
It was like the Cardinals? Yes, it was. Wow. How do you write it? Yeah, I can just remember. Yeah, I can see it. And how you feel, you put it another piece of gun on you realize. How about those Vikings?
是红雀队吗？是的，就是他们。哇。你是怎么想起来的？对，我还能记起来。对，我能看到那个画面。然后你的感觉是，当你嘴里又嚼上一块口香糖的时候你意识到。维京人队今年怎么样？
Are you looking forward to the Vikings are looking good this year? I don't know, we'll see. I mean, you know. You don't need to get shitty. I mean. Hey, sorry. Hang on a second. We're here with the morning Zoom crew.
你对维京人队今年的表现充满期待吗？我不知道，走着瞧吧。我是说，你知道的。你没必要这么扫兴。我是说。嘿，抱歉。等一下。我们现在和早间Zoom连线团队在一起。
Go ahead, Sean. You got another. You got another card to play? Here he comes. Go ahead, Sean. It's just the button, the red one. There you go. Oh.
说吧，肖恩。你还有。你还有别的牌要出吗？他来了。说吧，肖恩。就是那个按钮，红色的那个。这就对了。哦。
Go ahead, Will, you got a Flap, Flav, Fwap, Fwap, or something. Go ahead. Anybody? No? All right, we're going to be right back after these messages. No, no, no, no, no.
说吧，威尔，你有什么“扑通、拍打、啪嗒、啪嗒”的声音之类的。说吧。有人吗？没有？好吧，我们听个广告马上回来。不，不，不，不，不。
Oh, God. All right, wait, Steve. Wait, football. You played football. Go ahead. I was going to say theater stories. I was going to get into it because Steve did a lot of theater.
哦，天哪。好吧，等等，史蒂夫。等等，橄榄球。你打过橄榄球。说吧。我本来想说戏剧故事的。我正要切入这个话题，因为史蒂夫演过很多戏剧。
Well, I'm going to ask you a question about football first, but then get a theater story. I'll segue into it. Yeah, theater story. But football, what position did you play? And how long did you play? Because I played as a kid.
好吧，我先问你一个关于橄榄球的问题，然后再听戏剧故事。我会顺便过渡过去。对，戏剧故事。但橄榄球，你踢什么位置？你打了多久？因为我小时候也打过。
Did you? I played junior high and high school, and I was a cornerback, and I returned punts and kicks. Oh, wow. So you don't mind getting hit, do you? I do. You run right into the wall, don't you? I was scared shitless. I actually could not do a, I couldn't do a fair catch because I couldn't coordinate my hand and then catching the ball.
你打过？我初中和高中都打过，我是个角卫，我还负责回攻弃踢和开球。哦，哇。所以你不介意挨撞，对吧？我其实很介意。你直接往墙上撞，对吧？我吓得要死。我其实根本做不到，我做不到一次安稳接球，因为我无法协调我的手去接住飞来的球。
Oh, really? So I would just catch it. And they thought I was a badass, and it was just because I was. It was mentally challenged. I mean, I just fucking couldn't do it. No, I couldn't. I go, wait, well, ah! Now, that, what was going through your head there?
哦，真的吗？所以我总是直接硬接。他们以为我很牛逼，但其实那只是因为我。我的精神有点问题。我是说，我他妈就是做不到。不，我做不到。我心想，等等，呃，啊！现在，那个，你当时脑子里在想什么？
Were you thinking, I can't throw up the arm early enough to get it back down into catching position? Because if I throw up the hand too early, they're not going to see it, you know, right? Because you've got to throw it up late so that they're looking at you, right? But then it's too late to get the hand down into a catching position? Right. Like, when do you call for a fair catch? Am I calling it too early?
你在想，我不能把胳膊举得不够早以至于无法放下来摆好接球姿势？因为如果我把手举得太早，他们就不会看它了，你知道的，对吧？因为你得晚点把手举起来，这样他们才会看着你，对吧？但那样把手放下来摆好接球姿势就太迟了？对。什么时候该喊要“安稳接球”？我是不是喊得太早了？
Right. And I could make a touchdown. And I'm going to get a touchdown. And I'm going to yell that for that. Sure. Right. I played safety, but I don't know what that means anymore. But I remember that was my position. And I would be so nervous because I'd be in this, what is it called?
对。我本来可以完成一次达阵的。而我要为了那个去大喊大叫。当然。对。我打的是安全卫，但我现在不知道那是什么意思了。但我记得那就是我的位置。我会紧张得要命，因为我会处于这个，这叫什么来着？
Puddle? Shower. No, you know, when you would. Played safety in the shower. Let him finish his story. It's going to be great. Oh, my gosh. I'm crying.
达阵区？淋浴间。不，你知道的，当你。在淋浴间里打安全卫。让他把故事讲完。这肯定会很精彩。哦，天哪。我都笑哭了。
Is there a vest on it all, Sean? Something bright and orange? Just an orange vest in the shower waiting for your folks to come through like a crossing guard, right? No. No, you're in the line of scrimmages. That's what it's called?
那里有背心吗，肖恩？某种亮橙色的东西？只是淋浴间里的一件橙色背心，等着你们这群人像交通协管员一样走过去，对吧？不对。不对，你是在截锋线上。那是这么叫的吗？
In the line of scrimmages. That's a book. You're in the stance. You're in the stance, ready for the book. What is that called? You're in the whatever. And I would be so nervous because I would, the guys,
在截锋线上。那是一本书。你摆好姿势。你摆好姿势，准备看书。那叫什么来着？你处于那个什么状态。我会紧张得要命，因为我……
cross from me would be like, I'm going to fuck you. I'm going to fuck you. I'm going to beat the shit out of you. Whatever they're going to, they're talking shit right before the ball is snapped. So you may have been lined up in the wrong position as a safety. If you were on the line. Yeah. I don't know about that.
我对面的人会说，我要搞砸你。我要干死你。我要把你打得屁滚尿流。不管他们说什么，他们就是在球被开出之前喷垃圾话。所以你作为一个安全卫，可能排错了位置。如果你站在前线上。对。我不确定是不是这样。
Oh, is that what it is? Anyway, I would get so scared because I would be so intimidated that I would take it personally. What did? Did you hear what he said to me? Yeah, totally. That's exactly what. That's why they had you start lining up in the shower. That's right.
哦，是这样吗？不管怎样，我会吓坏的，因为我会感到太恐慌了，以至于把这些都当真了。什么？你听到他对我说什么了吗？对，完全是。那就是为什么他们让你开始在淋浴间里排队。没错。
I'm going to sue you. Now, Steve, how'd we get to macaroni art As a title of your company there? Are you cooked? No, Rick and I were just, you know, we just want to make shit, basically. Right. And we were like, hey, man, if it's like, we'll just do stuff. Like macaroni art, like his kids, if you blew it to the paper.
我要起诉你。话说回来，史蒂夫，你们公司怎么会起名叫“通心粉艺术”的？你们脑子烧坏了吗？不，瑞克和我当时就是，你知道的，我们只是想搞点东西出来，基本上就这样。对。然后我们就想，嘿，老兄，如果行得通的话，我们就随便弄点东西。就像通心粉艺术，就像他小孩子那样，如果你把它吹到纸上。
Scale of 1 to 10, how high were you guys when you came up with this? Yeah, what was the substance? Six. Six. Okay, good. Thank you for the honest answer. No, but it came quick. When did Sam Rockwell run into your life?
满分10分，你们想出这个名字的时候磕了多少？对，抽了什么？6分。6分。好吧，谢谢你的诚实回答。不，但这个灵感来得很快。山姆·罗克韦尔是什么时候闯入你的生活的？
Sam and I have known each other since early in New York. Yep. And then we did a movie together called Safe Men. Sure, yes. Which was really with Giamatti. Yeah. It was a great. John Hamburg's first movie, and he wrote it, he's brilliant.
我和山姆从在纽约早期就认识了。对。然后我们一起拍了一部电影叫《安全帽》。没错，是的。那部片子还有吉亚玛提。对。那是一部很棒的。约翰·汉堡的第一部电影，他写的剧本，他太才华横溢了。
It's brilliant. It's like, it's one of those movies that I get approached every once in a while somebody will come up and say, hey, that plays, that played it on a loop in our friend house or whatever. Well, now you know, Jason's directing Sam, you probably know that as we speak. Are you directing Sam right now? Yes, sir. Just finished. Great. Just finished.
太天才了。这部电影属于那种每隔一段时间就会有人跑来跟我说，嘿，那部片子在我们朋友家里循环播放过之类的。好吧，现在你知道了，杰森正在导演山姆的戏，你可能在谈话当时就知道这事。你现在在导演山姆的戏吗？是的，长官。刚刚杀青。太棒了。刚刚杀青。
Oh, you're done with the actors, Jay, but you have to go back and shoot another stuff? We're shooting with two other actors. And Sam himself is probably going to be replaced, but it's not that much to reshoot. This late this late. Yeah, well, I wanted to get all the way to the end to see if he's going to pull it out. And it just never got better. But it's not a lot of scenes.
哦，你已经拍完演员的戏了，杰伊，但你还得回去补拍别的镜头吗？我们正和另外两个演员一起拍。山姆本人可能要被换掉，但其实不需要补拍太多。这么晚了，这么晚了。对，好吧，我本来想看到最后看看他能不能挺过去。但情况一直没有好转。不过没多少戏份。
It'll be fine. It'll be good. Steve, what's your availability? I'm open. I'm good. Wait to go. Back to macaroni art. Do you develop things for other people and other things?
没事的。会挺好的。史蒂夫，你最近有空吗？我很空。我随时行。干得漂亮。回到通心粉艺术。你们会为其他人开发项目吗？
Or just for you guys? Careful, Steve. You're about to get a script in your inbox. I mean, really careful. It's just our stuff right now, it's, you know, we're, We got a we got like a docuseries we did on a chef, Weed and Michael that's in town here. Got it. And, you know, we're doing our own stuff right now.
还是只为你们自己人？小心点，史蒂夫。你的收件箱里马上就要收到一份剧本了。我是说，真的要小心。目前只有我们自己的项目，你知道的，我们正……我们有一个关于厨师维德和迈克尔的纪录片系列，就在这里拍摄。明白了。而且，你知道的，我们现在都在做自己的事情。
Every time I think, I keep looking at that art and I keep thinking about my favorite New Yorker cartoon of the one, the piece of rigatone pizza pasta, he's on the phone. He's like, right? And he's got a face of it. And he says, Fusili, you crazy bastard, how the hell are you? It's my favorite I'm funny I was going to say I need to get some
每次我想起，我一直看着那个艺术品，我就会想起我最喜欢的《纽约客》漫画，那是一个通心粉披萨面食，他在打电话。他好像在说，对吧？然后他脸上带着表情。他说，胖子，你这个疯狂的混蛋，最近怎么样？这是我最喜欢的。我很搞笑，我本来想说我得弄点……
David Cross merch I did a movie of David and it was amazing He's the man He's such an incredible funny Dude
大卫·克劳斯的周边商品。我和大卫拍过一部电影，太棒了。他真是个传奇。他是个如此不可思议、幽默的家伙。
An incredible stand-up too Yeah Now when you're not making Macaroni art And you're not doing Your million things You seem to be everywhere What are you doing
也是个不可思议的单口喜剧演员，对吧。好啦，当你没有在制作通心粉艺术品，也没有在忙你那一百万件事的时候，你好像无处不在。你在做什么？
What are you doing with your time Like what's the thing when you're back there that you're doing that's not related to your craft, your art, or your whatever, what do you do? I live on a farm, so I, that keeps, you know, I work on the farm. What do we got on the farm? What do you know? I got a couple horses, I got some goats.
你都在用时间做什么？就像你在后台时，那些和你的手艺、你的艺术或者别的什么无关的事情，你都在做些什么？我住在农场里，所以，这让我，你知道的，我在农场里干活。我们在农场里有什么？你知道吗？我有几匹马，我有一些山羊。
I, uh, I fix stuff. I mow my fields. I, I've just spent eight days trimming all my trees. Do you drink the goat, do you drink the goat milk or anything? No, just point and laugh. Point and laugh, yeah. They're pets. Are they pets?
我，呃，我修理东西。我割草坪。我刚刚花了八天时间修剪了我所有的树。你会喝山羊奶还是别的什么吗？不，只会指着它们笑。指着它们笑，对。它们是宠物。它们是宠物吗？
Okay. And then what, tell me about cutting these trees down. So you're up there, you got yourself like a lift or something? Or do you have yourself a bunch of ladders? No, I have an extended pole saw, and then I have a hand saw. And that's really all you need. That's kind of a gym. And then you got one of those chippers and you get all that stuff on the ground,
好吧。然后，告诉我关于砍树的事。所以你在上面，你用了升降机之类的东西吗？还是你用了一堆梯子？不，我有一把加长的杆锯，然后我有一把手锯。这就是你真正需要的一切。这简直像是在健身。然后你有一个那种碎木机，把地上的东西都清理干净，然后你得把它们都粉碎掉吗？
then you got to grind it all up? No, then I have a huge bonfire that I start. And when the coals are, you know, you've got to have a real dry one that's got a lot of wood in it. And then you keep the fire going, basically. It's so hot that you can put anything green on top. And so I have a side-by-side, you know, mule, Kawasaki mule. And I fill that up and I go to the fire and I throw it in.
不，接下来我会点燃一个巨大的篝火。当余烬，你知道的，你必须得用一堆非常干燥且有很多木头的东西。然后你基本上就一直让火烧着。火势非常大，你可以在上面扔任何绿色的植物。所以我有一辆全地形车，你知道的，川崎的Mule。我把车装满，然后开到火堆旁，把东西扔进去。
I just keep going. Jesus. I mean, look at the three of us. I have no idea what to do. I'm so worried about getting a callus, just even hearing it. Well, this is a podcast. I put my headphones on and I go all day. Really?
我就这样一直干下去。天哪。我是说，看看我们这三个人。我完全不知道该怎么做。光是听到这些，我就担心自己手上会磨出老茧。好吧，这是个播客。我戴上耳机，一整天都在干活。真的吗？
Yeah, yeah. Wow. So you got a bunch of rideable pharmaceuticals. equipment out there. That would be fun for me. You got any of like those handsome green John Deere things? The gators? I do. I have a, you know, big tractor that I pull a 12-foot bat way. That's got to be fun going down to one of those stores and buying those things, huh? Like a real man. They're a little pricey. It gets so hot down there. You're on your tractor, mowing the lawn. But you know what? You get on a tractor and you mow, you just slow down.
对，对。哇。所以你那里有很多可以驾驶的农用设备。那对我来说会很有趣。你有什么那种帅气的绿色约翰迪尔机器吗？Gator（多功能车）？我有。我有，你知道的，一个大拖拉机，用来拉一个12英尺的割草机。去那种商店买这些东西一定很有趣吧？像个真正的男人一样。它们有点贵。在那里干活太热了。你坐在拖拉机上割草。但你知道吗？当你坐上拖拉机开始割草时，你就会慢下来。
It's like forced meditation. Are you sipping on a sweet tea? Sorry. I don't like the sweet tea. I like just plain tea. Sorry, it's all like you. You got any air conditioning on those riding mowers, by the way? No, open. I used to have a cab with AC,
这就像是被迫冥想。你在喝冰甜茶吗？抱歉。我不喜欢甜茶。我只喜欢原味茶。抱歉，这听起来像是在说你。顺便问一下，你那些骑乘式割草机上有空调吗？没有，是敞开式的。我以前有一个带空调的驾驶室，
but when it breaks, then it's like you're in hell. Because you can't, can't recamp. When the AC breaks and you can't take the doors off. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Tell me. So, Steve, now you've got Chad Powers.
但当它坏了的时候，那就跟在地狱里一样。因为你没法，没法拆掉它。当空调坏了而且你又不能把门卸下来的时候。对，对，对。告诉我。所以，史蒂夫，你现在有了《查德·鲍尔斯》。
Yeah. It's Aaron right around now. September 3rd, it drops. Yes, September 3rd. All episodes, season 2. This is with that... That Glenn Powell guy. That piece of ass, Glenn Powell.
对。就在这附近上映。9月3日上线。是的，9月3日。第二季全集上线。这是和那个……那个格伦·鲍尔合作的。那个性感尤物，格伦·鲍尔。
Yeah. I love Glenn. He's a great guy. He's a very nice guy. Nice guy, easy to look at. He's got talent coming out the ears. Yeah. He's so fucking good in this show.
对。我爱格伦。他是个好人。他是个非常 nice 的人。人很好，看着也养眼。他的才华简直满得要溢出来了。对。他在剧里表现太他妈棒了。
Yeah. It's... I'm like, dude, when we showed up first day, I'm like, my God, he's in prosthetics. You know, he's like, playing this crazy character. And it's like, oh my God, man, you've got to swing hard.
对。这真是……我当时就想，老兄，当我们第一天到片场时，我就想，天哪，他戴着假体。你知道的，他就像是在扮演一个疯狂的角色。这就像是，哦天哪，老兄，你得全力以赴。
This is a big swing, dude. Yeah. Like you can't, you got to go all in, man, or else what do you do? Right. Yeah, you have to. Is it Peyton Manning associated with the show at all? Yeah, Peyton and Eli.
这是一次巨大的冒险，老兄。对。就像你不能有所保留，你得全情投入，老兄，否则你还能做什么？对。没错。佩顿·曼宁和这部剧有什么关联吗？对，佩顿和伊莱。
Eli did a video that so many people saw where he put prosthetics on. He went to Penn State. And the only person that knew it was him, was the coach, the head coach. So he's like, you know, at the walk on tryout. And he's just slinging these balls and people. You can see him.
伊莱拍过一个视频，很多人都看过，他戴上了假体。他去了宾夕法尼亚州立大学。唯一认出他来的人是教练，主教练。所以他就像是在，你知道的，在公开试训的时候。他一直在疯狂地传球给别人。你能看出来。
Who's this weird dude that's like 30, you know? So that was the premise that Michael Waldron and Glenn. They pitched it and they said that it's the series. And I read it and I thought this is the dumbest thing I've ever read. This is crazy. Yeah, right. prosthetics? How is this going to work? And it works?
这个看起来30岁左右的怪人是谁？所以这就是迈克尔·沃尔德伦和格伦构思的背景。他们把它推销出去，并说这就是这个系列剧。我读了剧本，心想这是我读过的最蠢的东西。这太疯狂了。对，没错。戴假体？这怎么行得通？结果它行得通了？
How about that? It's really great. And you got the gang from Omaha are still involved. They're producers on it, I imagine. Payton, you have to deal with notes from Peyton. These two guys. This fucking guy. You know what I mean?
怎么样？真的很棒。而且来自奥马哈的那些家伙仍然参与其中。我想他们是制片人，对吧？佩顿，你得处理来自佩顿的意见。这两个家伙。这他妈的家伙。你知道我的意思吗？
Go ahead. Go ahead. Let it out, man. No, you just got the incomings from Peyton. And it's just like, you know what I mean? This fucking guy. We love Peyton. We love them both.
说吧。说吧。宣泄出来吧，老兄。不，你只是收到了佩顿发来的消息。这就好像是，你知道我的意思吗？这他妈的家伙。我们爱佩顿。我们两个都爱。
We love them both. Yeah, those guys. We love all three of them. You know? Oh yeah, and Coop. Will. Well, we love. Yeah, Will, you get Will going on Coop, boy.
我们两个都爱。对，那几个家伙。我们这三个都爱。你知道吗？哦对，还有库珀。威尔。好吧，我们爱。对，威尔，你让威尔去对付库珀，老兄。
We'll be here all day. Have you ever met Coop before? Steve? No. The third. Oh, my God. No, I haven't. He's an absolute jam of a guy.
我们得在这儿待上一整天。你以前见过库珀吗？史蒂夫？没有。老三。哦，天哪。没有，我没见过。他绝对是个极品好人。
We love. The Secret Sauce. Oh, you're a secret. It's a fun show, man. I get to play a coach. I mean, it's like, it's like the things, the check marks that you have is like a 10-year-old. Like, wouldn't it be cool someday to like, I want to be a coach? I want to be inspiring and I want my team to run out after me.
我们爱。秘制酱汁。哦，你还挺神秘。这是一部有趣的剧，老兄。我演了一个教练。我的意思是，这就像是，这就像是你10岁时心目中的人生打卡清单。就像，总有一天这会很酷吧，我想当一个教练？我想成为鼓舞人心的人，我希望我的队员在我身后奔跑。
I can check that off. You know, I want to be in a Western. Have they done that? Yeah, I did that this season. God, you've played so, I'm just thinking you've done so many different characters, so many different, like in so many different levels. Character actor. Well, yeah, I mean, please, but I mean, like, we should all be so lucky.
我可以把这个打勾了。你知道的，我想拍一部西部片。他们拍过吗？对，我这一季拍了。天哪，你演过这么多，我只是在想你扮演过这么多不同的角色，这么多不同的，在这么多不同的层面上。性格演员。好吧，对，我是说，拜访一下，但我的意思是，我们都该觉得足够幸运了。
We should all be so lucky to be able to play all these, you know, do all these different things. And is there something that's out there before we let you go because we kept you forever, but is there something out there that you're like, I want to do it. Like you were saying, like, you always dreamed to do it like doing a coach, playing a coach, is there kind of a role out there that you're something that you've always wanted to do
我们都该觉得足够幸运，能去扮演所有这些，你知道的，做所有这些不同的事情。在我们让你离开之前，有没有什么——因为我们留了你太久了——有没有什么是你在想，我想去做的。就像你刚才说的，你一直梦想着去做的事，比如扮演一个教练，有没有那种你一直想演但还没演过的角色类型呢？
that you haven't done yet? I don't, no, I don't know. I really, I mean, I could say, I would love to go back to the theater. I'd like to do that, you know. But as far as like something specific, I really feel like if, you know, I wanted to be in a war movie.
我没有，不，我不知道。我真的，我是说，我可以这么说，我很乐意回到戏剧舞台。我很想做那个，你知道的。但至于具体某个角色，我真的觉得如果，你知道的，我想演一部战争片。
I wanted to be in a Western. and I wanted to experience that. I've experienced all those things. And now it's like, it's a surprise. It's like, do you want to play this guy that's like in silo that hasn't seen anyone for 40 years? And he's basically 11 years old. Yeah. And he's alone.
我想演一部西部片。并且我想去体验那些。我都体验过所有这些了。现在这就变成了一种惊喜。这就好像是，你想演那个在《基地》里40年没见过任何人的家伙吗？他基本上才11岁。对。而且他独自一人。
He's been alone for 40 years. I was like, yeah, that's amazing. Oh, my God. Yeah. And then you just did a movie with your daughter. Like, that's pretty awesome. I mean, you're living on your dreams. Yeah, it's really cool.
他独自生活了40年。我当时就想，对，太棒了。哦，天哪。对。然后你刚刚和女儿一起拍了一部电影。这太棒了。我是说，你正在把梦想变成现实。对，真的很酷。
Yeah. Good for you, pal. Yeah. Steve, listen, man, big, we're just such big fans. Thank you for showing up for us. We're lucky to have you. Man, thank you, you guys, I was so stoked to be on this. You guys are amazing.
对，真为你高兴，老兄。对。史蒂夫，听着，老兄，我们真的是超级粉丝。谢谢你赏脸来我们的节目。我们有你加入真是太幸运了。老兄，谢谢你们，我能来这里太兴奋了。你们太棒了。
Keep that macaroni art coming, okay? Please. Just send us all some macaroni merch. Yeah, thank you, Steve. Chad Powers comes out. September 3rd. It drops the new season, and she dances is going to be available on Peacock.
请继续把那些通心粉艺术带给我们，好吗？拜托了。给我们所有人寄点通心粉周边吧。好的，谢谢你，史蒂夫。《查德·鲍尔斯》要上映了。9月3日。新一季上线，而且她跳舞的节目将在 Peacock 上播出。
Dude, you got it all going on. The great Steve's on. Thank you. Thank you, Steve. Thank you, Steve. Thanks, guys. Good to see you. Bye, pal.
老兄，你真是全盘皆赢啊。伟大的史蒂夫来了。谢谢。谢谢你，史蒂夫。谢谢你，史蒂夫。谢谢你们，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。再见，老兄。
See ya. Steve Zahn, the number of characters he's played. I'd love to put, I'd love to put like side by side all his looks just to be like, wow, look at how different he is in every single. It's just like a mosaic, all the characters that he's played. He's played. Yeah, and then when you pull back, those images of spells Steve Zon. Oh, sorry, Steve Zon. Oh, we don't make one bit, yes.
再见。史蒂夫·赞恩，他演过的角色数量。我很想把，我很想把我把他所有的造型并排放在一起，只为了感叹一句，哇，看看他在每一部里都是多么不同。这就像是一幅马赛克，他演过的所有角色。他演过的角色。对，然后当你把画面拉远，那些形象拼出了史蒂夫·赞恩的名字。哦，抱歉，是史蒂夫·赞恩。哦，我们一点也没说错，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you, I, he's one of those guys every. time you turn something, every time he shows up, you're like, oh, yeah, man. Not only am I in good hands, I'm so happy to see him. So many, yeah. How exciting would it be to, like, act in a scene with him, too. Like the very first day, you're just kind of looking across from them. They're about to roll and you're like, yeah, I wonder what's coming my way.
对，对，对。你，他是那种每次只要你打开某个节目，每次他一出现，你就会想，哦，太棒了。不仅我不用担心剧情了，而且我看到他会超级高兴。好多啊，对。和他一起在场景里演戏会是多么令人兴奋的一件事啊。就像第一天，你只是隔着场景看着对方。他们正准备开拍，而你会想，天哪，不知道会有什么好戏等着我呢。
Yeah. Are you ready? Right. Oh, God. The nerves. Talk about nerves. Speaking of getting, no, not yet. Speaking about getting ready.
对。你准备好了吗？对。哦，天哪。这种紧张感。说到紧张感。说到准备，不，还没有。说到准备。
Willie, looks like you are getting ready to start working. Yes. A astronaut coming up. You got a nice astronaut haircut. You're looking really good. Have you started shooting yet? No, no, we're about a month away. A month out?
威利，看起来你正准备开始工作了。对。接下来要演宇航员了。你剪了个漂亮的宇航员发型。你看起来状态真不错。你开始拍摄了吗？没有，没有，我们还有一个月左右。还有一个月？
Yeah, just over a month until we start. I mean, it's one of the things I'm all joking aside. It's one of the things I'm really looking forward to is you playing that part and watching that series because it's right up my alley. And I can't wait to see you do it. Yeah, I'm excited. My character is not an astronaut himself.
对，距离开机还有一个多月。我是说，抛开玩笑不谈，这是我真正期待的事情之一，就是看你扮演那个角色并观看那个系列剧，因为这完全符合我的胃口。我迫不及待地想看你的表演。对，我很兴奋。我的角色本身不是宇航员。
He's a former, you know, pilot, test pilot, whatever. He's in charge of the astronaut program. And it's pretty Is there tension there between the astronauts and you? Like, hey, you can't tell us what's going on. You've never been an astronaut. Is there a line like that? There's a lot of regret.
他是一个前任，你知道的，飞行员，试飞员什么的。他负责宇航员项目。而且这相当……宇航员和你之间会有矛盾吗？比如，嘿，你不能告诉我们该怎么做。你又没当过宇航员。会有这样的台词吗？有很多遗憾。
There's a lot of regret. There's no line like that. I mean, I don't know. By the way, do you mind if we borrow that? Yeah, we'll say, fine, fine with me. So, wait, there's a lot of regret on your character's part because he never got a... We're going to watch.
有很多遗憾。没有这样的台词。我是说，我不知道。顺便问一下，你介意我们借用一下那个吗？对，我们说，行，我没问题。所以，等等，你角色的身上有很多遗憾，因为他从来没有……我们要看了。
We're going to watch. He wanted to get up. He wanted to leave the atmosphere so bad. Just watch my eyes. Just watch my eyes. You're going to tell the story right there in the windows? Well, I'm a storyteller. Yeah, with the eyes.
我们要看了。他渴望飞上去。他太渴望离开大气层了。只要看我的眼睛。只要看我的眼睛。你打算直接用眼神在镜头里讲故事吗？好吧，我是一个讲故事的人。对，用眼神。
You ready for this? You ready? Sure. It's where? It's where? It's where? Oh, Shani's got more. Yeah, we're going to...
你准备好了吗？你准备好了吗？当然。在哪儿？在哪儿？在哪儿？哦，香尼还有更多存货。对，我们要……
Oh, wow. We'll trim that up. There you guys. There it comes. I just didn't want the train to pass us... Bye! That was great. That was worth it.
哦，哇。我们会把它修剪一下。你们看。它来了。我只是不想让火车错过我们……再见！太棒了。这很值得。
That was worth it. We're going to bring it back. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这很值得。我们要把它拿回来。Smartless 是由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjav 和 Bennett Barbico 100% 有机手工制作的。Smart less。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。